[Musik]
da wirst du gott herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen blog meine
damen und herren
morgen wird er richtig motiviert heute
steht so einiges auf dem programm meine
damen und herren sind wendet eine nicht
lachen challenge dazu kommen wir gleich
wir werden heute mit dem mond von
unserem nachbarn gassi gehen das haben
wir uns erlaubt also wir haben quasi
heute für nur für das strömt dann werden
wir nach bielefeld fahren weil ich eine
kooperation mit einer fast food kette
habe die allerdings auf insgesamt
stattfinden also in diesem video wird
quasi keine werbung direkt vorkommen
aber das werden wir heute auch noch
waffen und wir werden die schon gesagt
eine nicht lachen schöner zu machen die
die nachher stadt sind wir dafür
zusammen raff haben werden und in der
nicht laden challenge werden auch noch
diese jelly beans tonvorkommen ich habe
das ganze schon mal mitreden derart
gemacht also lokal kann es ja jetzt bei
hier kurz zeigen wie das damals war
meine damen und herren wir erstmal
wir sind wieder zu hause angekommen
freunden essen war heftig schafe sterben
jetzt unser nachbar übergehen denn die
haben einen labrador haben die kein
wasser sondern also wir haben jetzt den
hund die am start danke nochmal lassen
dafür deinen hund hier in filmen dürfen
und sarah meinte das ist ein dickes ist
aber ein labrador der flora ganz kleine
gassen so flora hat noch die line und
der haut direkt
wir sind jetzt an einem hundeplatz
angekommen wo flora tatsächlich alleine
rum laufen kann der flora ja die thora
darf ist war oma in gold alter
das ist ja der hammer
[Musik]
vlotho va
wir stehen hier alleine und bürger hat
ihrem stoff da hinten und hunde sind so
leicht zu beeindrucken einfach das
scheiß stock wir gucken uns immer so
videos einmal instagram wie die goldenen
bücher zu dumm sind uns der schwimm und
flora zwei jahre alten stocken kommt
nilpferd angeschwommen freunde und gold
[Musik]
kräftig nass geworden gerade hunde sagen
sich hallo wir sind jetzt einer
viertelstunde park und doch könnte ich
wieder zurückkommen weil sie den stock
auf jeden fall behalten will
die sieht so süß aus wenn man die namen
von die augen brannten wieder überhaupt
keine hintergründe das gassi gehen war
echt nice also ich hab noch nie wirklich
so ein hund erlebt der so aktiv ist aber
auch so lieb obwohl salat ein paar
probleme unser plan ist auf jeden fall
sandra abzuholen falls es andere nicht
kennt jemand kurzer ausschnitt
[Musik]
und dann werden wir alle zusammen nach
wieder geld vorhanden ist ja auch noch
mit am start
und dort werden wir in einen tierpark
fahren weil wir mögen tiere geht hier
mitfahren wenn ihr diese hinweis die
links zu nierensteinen und rechts das
unbedingt machen deswegen 74 wir sind im
tierpark angekommen
und da also ein baum tiere hier sitzen
jule und ich und da hinten sitzt sarah
war mit ihrem freund sandra kauft seit
einer viertelstunde futter für tiere
angeht besteht in deinem leben kann ich
vielleicht mal hoch schauen sie dann
vielleicht mal hoch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der juli ist die das aus der hand aber
hey hey ich auch futter da hinten sind
edel die wollten wir gott führt dann
aber hier ist ein fütterungsverbot
dürfen wir dir das foto dann geben
beides gelingt hier händen ist einfach
wie jude so die ganze zeit am ende mein
gott die sind richtig süßes kleines baby
kaninchen und sie sitzt einfach
komplette messen
so sagt krümel und fühlen dass mein
altes kaninchen und das muss man leider
abgeben halter nicht gestorben ist
dort hab sie selig alter als normale
wiener sind ja schon nicht schön aber
die hier ist mein bislang
ich habe also es ist denn wir müssen uns
wieder aus dem tierpark weiter sind so
krass viele mücken und wespen gewesen
das heißt meine damen herren wir fahren
jetzt hast du hast du warum niemand im
soll wir hier und werden jetzt auf den
titel zu sprechen kommen nämlich einen
nicht lang challenge dafür habe ich mir
extra diese dienen basel bestellt mit
denen ich damals meine nicht lachen
challenge gemacht habe
willich land challenge nehmen waren und
ich teilen und sandra versucht uns
irgendwie zum lachen zu bringen und
derjenige der als erster das muss dann
einmal in diesem rennen hier drehen
bekommt dann in libyen die entweder
total lecker schmeckt oder nach kotze
oder irgendwie sowas alle meine damen
und herren wir befinden uns hier heute
schon wasser geholt und will aber habe
ich auch schon weil jude sie liebt diese
wunde
wir machen also dass wir alle ernst in
die kamera schauen und sandra
irgendetwas vor werden als erstes eine
regung zeigt sandra beurteilt hier die
schiedsrichterin die mussten ca 15
zentimeter lang steigung bieten eine
feuchte öffnung
also ich drehe jetzt weil hier dieses
komische ding und ich habe nein tutti
frutti oder stinkesocken nennt man einen
übergewichtigen vegetarier biotonne luca
liga freunde und wir haben diesmal die
gelbe das heißt entweder eine einfache
chemische oder ein gutes popcorn
vorkommt was sagt ein tornado zu einer
peiner halte eine liste fest ich blase
gleich juli drehen freunde sie hat grün
also limette oder jahr gemäht rasen als
etf das ist ganz okay er selbst sei
abgeführt die gummienten
da hat hundekacke oder schokoladen kommt
zum spiel am brühl war dass die
hundescheiße
wir waren erstens wäre er gelacht da hab
ich ja ja sag alter wasser ist er werde
zum glück haben sondern diesmal
kurzdienst essen ja okay wir machen so
nicht lassen denn schmidt boden und
sandra steht jetzt hier wachsen die
ganze zeit ist ja das ist mir zu cala
ratjada einen tiger bikini bestellter
und so entweder per iglu oder zahnpasta
das ist nicht das nicht so schlimm
zahnpasta aber richtig geil
[Musik]
überhaupt nicht
ich hab angst ist dafür jetzt schwer ist
weil ich ein bisschen dicker bild und
hat uns untergeht
die frutti
46 naja wenns nicht so wär dann ist
wirklich keine gut sein
sie begrenzt die kosten sonst ist
scheiße
[Gelächter]
und wir haben das blaue das leben ist
wie durchfall scheiße aber nein muss
essen ein must be so ohne toilette
[Musik]
entfaltet
deswegen weil hier in der badewanne
[Gelächter]
wir nehmen beide einen also ich drehe es
mal freunde wir haben die blauen das
geht eigentlich ja klar wir müssen beide
jetzt ist hier showdown zwischen sarah
und sandra ihr dürft keine regung zeigen
dass showdown zwischen es andere und
sarah freunde wir müssen euch zwar zum
lachen bringen und andere doch mal
gesondert verloren
was ist weiß und stattdessen eine war
dass die frage ist so zu kommen was ist
weiß und steht wirklich beim essen
sperma
es ist kopf
ich glaube die schnittchen unterschied
gar das ist kommt nicht an müller alter
leute uns ist echt ein bisschen schlecht
nach der nicht lassen challenge ärzte
eltern gehen jetzt aber deswegen zuerst
nach dem grillen werde ich euch übrigens
auch eine neue sequenz blog inhalt
dingsbums hier vorstellen ich hab noch
einmal keinen richtigen namen dafür so
was wie die interviews nicht ab und zu
so dumm machen
dann gibt es ihn jetzt hält ortsteil mit
balu dann gibt es kommentare
kommentieren und jetzt hier kommen jetzt
noch nicht für den neuen block inhalts
concept.de vorbereitet habe weil sander
ihre kopfhörer bonn vergessen hat und
die fliegt halt mal nach cala ratjada
das heißt wir müssen hier jetzt
umbringen
die kopfhörer gegeben angekommen freunde
und nun kommen wir zu dem neuen blog
inhalts konzept ahnung wie man das ganze
nennen soll und zwar könnt ihr mir unter
einzelbilder unser tweets von mir oder
beispielsweise unter diesem blog jetzt
hier einfach irgendeinen witz
unterschreiben der dann vielleicht in
dieser sequenz jetzt reinkommt
du bist der welt haben jetzt alle
gelacht wie nennt man ein weißes mammut
helmut lustig forscher haben
herausgefunden sind dann aber wieder
eingegangen ist zu tun wie heißt der
bruder von 11 bis 12
ich frage mich schon warum ich das hier
neu eingeführter was wächst unter der
erde und stinkt eine wurzel denken die
leute eigentlich was schwarz gelb macht
muss muss eine biene im rückwärtsgang
sammer was ist denn falsch bei euch in
den bz anzugeben ist echt oberarm sagt
er eine balance zum anderen ich habe
platzangst
[Musik]
was ist der gefährlichste tag für ein u
boot tag der offenen tür
was hat einer der ständig im dreieck
läuft kreislaufprobleme ich sag euch ich
werde mir den block an dieser stelle
[Musik]